okay okay enough about the cousins let's
have a conversation everybody in the
comedy community talking uh we have
michael che tim dillon beefing a little
bit online over an snl sketch uh michael
che is a comedian hilarious comedian uh
he's got netflix special is really
brilliant you should go check him out
and he's also the um
he's the head writer co-head writer of
snl
uh and then tim dillon hilarious
comedian he's got an amazing podcast uh
you should go check tim's stuff out i
mean i'm sure you guys know tim and uh
just brilliant appearances on rogan and
other pods etc and they're beefing over
this snl sketch the snl sketch uh was a
sesame street spoof but it was about ted
cruz so it was cruise street right and
uh part of that is uh pete davidson
playing joe rogan and uh he comes out
and this is this is over this whole beef
about uh big bird coming out on twitter
and saying that big bird got vaccinated
and ted cruz was very critical of that
it's like why are you trying to convince
kids that they should get vaccinated if
kids watch [ __ ] sesame street anymore
i don't think kids have watched sesame
street in 30 years but i think we were
the last generation no i made a comeback
did it really yeah yeah my friend's kid
loves elmo oh really yes i think it's
all brand around elmo but it's it's big
again believe it or not fair enough so
there's this whole sketch now a small
part of the sketch is the joe rogan park
yeah right and basically joe rogan comes
out and he's like what i do is i take
horse pills i take horse drugs and then
big bird's like well i'm not a horse you
think i should take that and he's like
well i'm a human i still take horse
pills and blah blah blah and um
basically what tim dillon said is there
a hundred different ways to do the
sketch and have it be funny the show is
just lazy mediocre hacks yes now
i'm assuming if you're one of the
writers of the sketch that makes you
feel away yep and then he he keeps going
oh
the show is now just lazy mediocre hacks
is the roughest one i think but then he
tweets more he says people saying snl
hasn't been funny since the 70s are
wrong farley rock sandler's myers norm
shario terry and molly shannon were
brilliant tracy morgan also the hater
mckinnon air was funny it's maybe the
singular greatest us comedy platform but
this sketch was bad and not bad because
it made fun of joe or ivor mikton but it
did it in the laziest way possible it
was talking points and not jokes comedy
shows can have a point of view mine does
but it should also occasionally have
comedy so he like it was a tweet series
yeah
yeah it was an attack on on snl or very
harsh criticism of essence yeah yeah
absolutely so i i can understand you
know if you're che and like that's your
show and this is the show that you've
been running for the last few years
specifically the section
that tim is being critical of yeah he's
basically saying yo it was good before
you yeah yeah
but now with you the [ __ ] sucks that's a
good ass point that's right so i can
understand how you might feel away about
that so then che comes out and he goes
lol you've got to be kidding me tim
dillon exclamation point question mark
excellent one question mark what's the
world coming to then he has two more
tweets one just goes tim dillon in all
caps with a question exclamation and
then one in bigger font just says tim
[ __ ] dylan yeah and then uh he says
look i don't want no trouble and then
this is the screenshot right here on the
car right yeah somebody was responding
to uh somebody's responding to che and
basically saying hey tim dillon makes
190 uh k a month on patreon and che goes
i don't care if it's a zillion which is
not true if he was making a zillion we
would all care yeah
a zillion dollars
you don't care if it's a zillion you
don't care if there's a person making a
zillion dollars
if they were literally making one
zillion dollars on patreon you wouldn't
care at all you'd still be making big
bird sketches if you knew you could make
a zillion dollars on [ __ ] patreon
that's that's not true that's not true
but uh
uh he goes he goes he goes jay goes i
know tim dillon and he ain't what you
think he is he's a sweet humble guy who
really tried to stand up got nowhere
became a media personality because it's
much easier and we're all very happy for
him but don't get fresh tim
whoa
now
there's a response somebody dms him and
says he's selling out theaters on tour
right now i'm a fan of both yours mind
you it's him and sam talent doing a
theater tour he just sold out the beacon
and chase said and we're all very proud
of him and you know i don't want no
trouble but in the words of prodigy and
then he does a uh a prodigy some lyric
from a song i honestly don't remember
because i couldn't screenshot that um
but then tim responds on twitter
to that he says here's the reality i
sell more tickets than michael che ever
has and i built something on my own that
he could never do che has done well for
a drunk who can barely read but his show
sucks and he knows it and then shay says
all fair points and i'm very proud of
him i don't want no trouble which i
thought was a funny back and forth on
both your ends yes uh and then he said
seriously folks what's the world coming
to che did and then he said there's so
many white guys of a certain size in my
dms right now right and they both just
go on to kind of like backtrack a little
bit yeah uh okay what are you guys
thoughts
can't y'all both just be funny and like
i don't know i jay you're you're on top
dude you don't got to worry about if
somebody been not beneath you but like
you've been a guy at snl for eight years
if a guy that is popping off now and got
hot in the last couple years is taking
shots at a show you work on yeah i can
see how you get defensive but also you
that show doesn't let you do you
right you're not going to get to do the
same [ __ ] on your netflix special
that that drops on tuesday as you would
on the sketch the netflix special is you
this is what nbc will let you put out
right right right
yeah i i
i think this this is che promoting a
special
you know what there's there's no chance
he gives a [ __ ]
you don't care yeah yeah yeah this is
tray promoting the special the special
also comes out when tomorrow tomorrow
we're today when this podcast comes out
yeah of course so yeah you're gonna
engage in a beef you don't have a
podcast you're not necessarily going out
and doing podcasts and all these other
platforms you still have to drum up
interest for your special right right
right it's not like throwing a billboard
up in [ __ ] times square does anything
anymore yeah you got to drum up interest
it's pretty convenient
that a day before the special comes out
or two days before the special comes out
there's a beef with one of the biggest
uh comedic media personalities yeah and
he gave you the alley-oop right i might
text at dylan i was like yo you gave him
every opportunity because everybody's
gonna go to his instagram to look at
what the beef is about and i promise you
there's probably just one picture saying
my special comes out the 16th yeah
that's it like i bet yeah no i didn't i
didn't see what this thing looked like i
guarantee that is exactly what it is
okay of course
jay's smart yeah this guy is smart yeah
he didn't accidentally become the
[ __ ] co-head writer of uh snl
you do that because you're smart
so
[ __ ] i mean if he was
that's literally all it is it's one box
this is hilarious
[Music]
and that's the name of the special shave
shane the devil love it uh this is
genius this is like rap tactics you got
the album coming out start the beef yeah
what would what would kanye do what
would 50 cent do yeah right what would
eminem do yeah this is classic rap
tactics brought into the comedy world
start the conversation now
motherfucker's gonna hate watch the
special yep all the tim's fans gonna
come out here like man i'm gonna show
you who's not funny i'm gonna show you
who's a what do you call him a failed
comic or something like that yeah
and then all those people count his
streams yeah yeah yeah do you know what
i'm saying yeah youtube took away the
dislike button
yeah they can't even dislike his [ __ ] if
if he puts out the trailer on youtube
yeah like this is this is not the first
time that a comic probably even tim has
criticized snl it happens all every week
comics say the [ __ ] show sucks yeah
every week yeah it's almost like
it's become exhausting for comics to
[ __ ] on it yeah like i'm getting
exhausted by it
and i think the reason is is because
like
a lot of comics hold it in such high
regard
yeah so like
by being maybe rejected or not included
in something that they hold you know is
such an important institution in comedy
hurts a lot so when you see it starting
to struggle and kind of not doing that
well like the numbers aren't what they
used to be mm-hmm and just that's nature
of like a changing sense of uh your
point i'm i'm pretty sure chase is not
going to be
i think this is this his last season on
snl i don't think he's gonna be there
that much longer so he's got his own
show on hbo i can't imagine you can
juggle them both he's been leaving snl
for the last five years
every time i talk to him i'm like is it
over yet now he got his hbo show though
so he could pour himself into that right
so i think this might be his actual i
assume he's leaving by next year so but
who cares
just i think now you got your hbo show
now you got your netflix special i don't
know how much longer you keep doing all
three you're going to focus on the
u-shit so to that point you wouldn't
really care if somebody's [ __ ] on the
show you're leaving a hunch and akash is
right with his hands my hunches are the
nicest bro
but who [ __ ] knows you're saying
there's other opportunities i'm saying
why would he be that protective of a
show that he's probably leaving like you
got two other nobody's [ __ ] on the
michael chase you're always gonna be
protective over the things that you make
everybody's susceptible to criticism if
somebody shits over something that's
yours you're gonna i'm trying to agree
with you you know what i mean i'm just
saying [ __ ] you know let me agree with
you yeah no no no what i'm saying is
you're i don't i'm i understand what
you're saying i'm not saying he's
necessarily i don't think that he'll be
but that's just my personal opinion as
much as i try to tell him to leave yeah
i don't think it will happen right um
mark what are your thoughts yeah i mean
same exact thing i think they both
benefit in the beef because like tim's
fans will be like yo we went up against
you know the head writer of snl like the
old institution and like we won yeah so
like we're the best like it validates
their you know fan base and then shay's
gonna get all the streams and he's
probably to get some residual fans that
are like oh it actually was not bad like
i actually enjoyed it he needs people to
see how funny he is because that's the
thing he's funny you're going to watch
the special and even if you don't like
what he had to say about him you got to
respect you're going to go nah he's
going to my point even if you're hate
watching you're going to go like oh it's
pretty good and there's gonna be a
percentage of those he knows he got the
goods so he could have the beef yeah i
do think that it was unfair
of him to say i think there's a couple
things that are going on that are unfair
um i think it's unfair for him to say
and it's almost like a
it's almost like a cardinal sin
like
to say you're saying to another comic
that they failed yeah now
so now tim is also saying that the show
is hack that's huge if he didn't use the
word that he said the show is just
unfunny hacks now exactly they said the
writers are hacks so he said you're a
hack so like they both kind of cross the
line now this is comedy culture there's
certain things you're kind of not
allowed to say to one another like
you're busting balls at the table you
don't talk really about someone's act
if somebody gets into like their act and
someone being hacky or someone doing
that yeah that's where
[ __ ] is actually important you're
talking about somebody's jeans
somebody's [ __ ] hair someone's jacket
whatever we're having fun
but once you start going into that one
thing that we're all very sensitive and
care about
now you're giving license for you to go
the [ __ ] right it's real then exactly
so
it's a tricky thing now
the the section of the sketch this is
what's interesting the sketch itself if
you watch the whole sketch
i actually didn't think it was bad like
there's a part with burt and ernie funny
that is actually very funny like i'm
looking at the writing and i'm going
into it defensive of joe you know what i
mean you know joe's my guy so if
anybody's being critical of joe i'm like
man [ __ ] you right yeah the guy did so
much for me so obviously but i watched
the whole thing and i was like okay
there's a couple funny moments the joe
thing
sucks sucks there's no joke
the joke is i take horse medicine which
we already disproved yeah it's like that
would have worked the week it came out
maybe the [ __ ] he's eating the [ __ ] he's
eating just make it elk like make it a
little bit funnier
but but but you see what i'm saying
about specifically like it's just dated
like yeah
bro
i don't know if chase this much of a
mastermind but part of me thought
like he did that [ __ ] on purpose here's
what's interesting
joe sketch
right
you're gonna have all the people who
[ __ ] with and defend joe
[ __ ] on that the whole internet's gonna
start talking they don't have trump to
criticize anymore right so you can't go
after trump you need the new version of
that you need the new divisive guy the
new divisive guy now cnn is trying to do
it is joe joe you make the show about
joe and then you make it if he's a true
mastermind right you make it
criticizable yeah unfair you make it
unfair it's a super funny pointed like
parody then everyone goes oh yeah that
was funny if it's hilarious you got to
give it up it doesn't make any news if
it's not if it's straight kind of hacky
right
like trust me if jay's on stage
that's not the joke he's making about
horse d worm yeah no way i
and maybe i say it's because i think
he's truly a great comedic mind yeah
i know for a fact that's not the joke
yeah there's no you know okay to
snl that's the 47 seconds they put
online on twitter tim dylan is
responding to a tweet that snl put out
oh so that's where i'm like because i
was like before you said that i was like
why would snl put that out that's the 47
seconds you want it out maybe you're
right maybe it is this will get
everybody talking about us it puts us
back in the spotlight as snl you always
need people talking about you and then
if you're che you're like yeah cool when
comics go at it i'm hey i'm i'm gonna
use that yeah and i get to promote my
[ __ ] yeah yeah yeah that is if he's a
mastermind no look best case scenario is
or like most uh genius chess move is
doing it and leaking it on purpose or
specifically choosing a purpose yeah
worst case is they just need people to
talk about the show and if you talk
about the [ __ ] man who's in
charge right now yeah joe pete there's
gonna have a conversation we're having a
conversation about it right now yeah we
talking about that [ __ ] now um
were talking a little about this
yesterday you had an interesting point
about like both of their potential
sensitivities
and um
i thought you speak on it a little bit
more i thought it was interesting so i
guess the point that i was trying to
extrapolate is like tim is so much made
outside of the industry and his whole
audience is just basically like almost
grassroots and it exists behind patreon
and it's like all his thing he has full
ownership whereas jay was like brought
into this pre-existing institution in
the system and he's just a part of it
yes and so a lot of his fans i think
initially probably came from snl that
were fans of snl and then became fans of
him right so he has to like sort of
moderate public perception a lot more
because he's been grandfathered into
this pre-existing system whereas tim is
sort of outside of that criticism
from like critics and like reviewers and
articles and [ __ ] like that because he
already has such like a prominent like
die hard fan base so basically in other
words like
che can get fired right and
his fans came to him through the show
and the institution right so they're not
going to stop watching the institution
right they're not going to stop being
snl fans right matter of fact if you if
che don't give them anything new they
might stop being cheap fans so che is
locked to the institution and he's got
his fans that he got outside of that and
some will rock with him
much less than the
the mountain of fans that are watching
snl and we are critical of snl's numbers
but it's still a very big popular show
there's no question right so
so i understand why he has to and i
think there's remarks saying why he has
to respond to public criticism more
because public criticism
is what could get him fired yeah i mean
him and shane are in very different
situations but public criticism is the
reason why shane's not on the show yeah
public criticism is probably the reason
why everybody who's been fired off the
show has fired off the show yeah a few
sketches come out people are like yeah
that person's not that funny and then
lauren's like i guess that person ain't
that [ __ ] fun yeah yeah audio see you
later so you gotta manage public
perception someone's coming at you
you've got to make them radioactive or
cut their legs out yeah that person has
a criticism that's
people seem to agree with you got to be
like well why is this person able to
critique yeah you're going to listen to
this guy you got to assassinate the
character it's like a me too yeah yeah
yeah man like if this girl's saying you
did some [ __ ] you got to go poor noise
yeah you know what i mean buy the
champagne bottles engrave them you got
to go after funny you got to go at it
yeah you got to go at the validity yep
right so
so i understand and i thought that was
really that was really a poignant
observation and uh and whereas tim on
the other end
is used to criticism of him but doesn't
have to care as much as long as that
criticism isn't coming from his fans as
long as his fans are appeased you can't
get fired yeah i didn't know that miles
uh had the little headphones in and it
sounded like
he had his hand over his ears and he's
bending down and i was like
am i so boring that
you have a headache like this
like literally he was bent over like
this like i cannot listen to another
[ __ ] word of this guy speak and then
i and then he took his hands off and
then thank god there were like little
airpods in here yeah okay miles you
almost really made me feel horrible
right there i felt like michael che
responding to it
dylan tweets here
but uh
funny yeah
but uh yeah so you you you understand
why why chay is reacting often time to
these critics
etc now i assume that he's doing that
for game yeah i assume he knows he could
rile up the internet and when it's time
to rile up the internet about something
that he has coming out maybe it's his
show maybe it's a special maybe it's
some project maybe it's a tour that he's
doing something i think he knows how to
engage and do that right and i think
that's a sophisticated chess move from a
guy who doesn't have
a mouthpiece to really promote his stuff
he also has the shield of the
institution so like people can criticize
snl and he can either just not take the
bait be like yeah that's snl i wasn't
involved whatever or if they do chris
says us and all of a sudden he can make
it personal and be like no that's my
thing that you're coming at yeah tim
never said anything about che
but if you're saying that the show is
hack stuff and he's the head writer it's
going to reflect ultimately on him but
he can choose to not opt in like if
you're coming at him going like yo
michael j is the worst whatever yeah
then you kind of have to respond if
someone shits on flagrant 2 i want to
respond right yeah but you're much more
intimate this is andrew schultz's
flagrant too it's not michael jay's snl
but if he's the responsible party for
the writing on the show if he's the one
that green lights all the things it's
like
it's like responding to a sub as a
rapper you don't have to respond to a
sub he didn't say michael chase is an
unfunny hacker but but sorry to cut you
but if somebody shits on rockefeller
records
jay-z got to feel the way about jay-z
jay-z is the owner he's him and dame
founded that that's a good point he
created it's like bleak being that bleep
being like yo how [ __ ] dare you come
at rock and they're probably criticizing
men in particular but the point is
i see what you're saying there's a
little bit more distance but you're
still going to personalize something
that you can personalize it that you are
100 tied to for example if the biggest
thing you're known for
is this institution and you take
responsibility for what's happening in
the institution even if if the
institution supersedes you that's the
biggest thing you're known if someone
shits on india
yeah yeah you know what i'm saying like
if someone shits on my favorite
basketball team on defensive yeah right
like we get defensive over the things
that we relate to i haven't been
spending five years saying i'm going to
leave india this is my last year on
india right right i mean i think it's
probably marketing and i we say this all
the time if somebody takes a little shot
it's like yo that guy's not even worth
it don't respond we say that to each
other this guy's not worth it that's not
worth it why would you get into that but
it is worth it if you've got some [ __ ]
to promote it's very worth it yeah it's
very worth it yeah
yeah it's interesting i bring that up
just to say he's positioned in a cool
way where he can either choose to opt in
or choose to not engage yeah and he took
this time to engage you know what's
funny is it is the way that he did it
now i know chase plugged in he's a comic
so he has to know what's happening in
the world and he has to know the
shifting of the guard and how like you
know traditional tv shows aren't really
doing what they used to do they're not
doing that for people's careers etc and
um
i thought it was a little while to say
the [ __ ] about uh and again you know
tim's opened it up with the hacks but
that was a little loud to say is a
failed comic because like what do how do
you judge the the success of a comedy